راويه راويه كيف هي الصوره من هناك خصوصا
اننا يعني بحسب كل الصور امامنا التي
ننقلها الان مباشره الاحتفالات بدات تعم
عموم تركيا
مع طبعا يعني
اعلان النصر لحزب اردوغان
راويه هل تسمعين نعم الاحتفال ان كان خارج
هذا نعم نعم اسمعك هل تسمعينني
مظاهر اذانه الاحتفال التي هي خارج مركز
العداله والتنميه لا زلنا غير متاكدين ان
كان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان رغم توافد
يعني بالصوره مقابلنا رغم توافد الناس الى
القصر الرئاسي بين الحين والاخر تصلنا
انباء وربما
كعاداته يلقي خطاب او يلقي كلمه مقتدبه
هنا ثم يذهب الى انقره ولكننا لسنا اكيد
من هذه المعلومه اود الاشاره الى نقطه
اعلنها وزير الداخليه التركي خلال ادلائه
بصوته نهارا تحدث عن تدابير احترازيه
بالمطارات بمراكز التسوق وايضا بالاماكن
العامه والمناطق السياحيه
احترازيا في حال نشبت اي احتجاجات بعد
اعلان
النتائج وذلك طبعا يبرر التواجد الامني
بهذه المناطق لا شك بانه يحسب لتركيا بانه
هذه الجوله لم تشبها تقريبا اي شائبه
عمليه الانتخابات منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى
جرت بكل ثلاثه كان هناك انتشار امني مكثف
وتواجد للشرطه بكل المراكز التي زرناها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات